yeah welcome to this video playing a GM
here from India let's India rod is he
have a name in there we did guwahati 16
year old from India are you love that
yeah I still got the texture moving as I
am so it's probably pretty fresh young
GM like 17 18 years old okay the Rue La
Paz let's see I is playing the old main
line rookie one nowadays they very often
play with d3 early now do you three yeah
this is just a mistake I'm getting the
other bishop now this is some rare
occurrence and for Grandmaster that he
makes this mistake giving up the bishop
I can take it next move as well don't
need to take it instantly um okay yeah
okay let's let's grab it it's just it's
just two bishops so c5 may be on but
it's not very comfortable you can play
various setups and I want to prevent
Bishop g5 play ruki 8 Bishop f8 Bishop
d7 and then go for d5
of course here it's not a matter of
equality black now needs to play for um
for 4h now with with with the two
bishops Bishop e7 and then t5s my lady I
want to open up the position for my two
bishops it's very likely that he will
play c4 at some stage to block d5 you
know yeah it must do that it's no one no
big alternative the question is somehow
to how to continue now it's not really
threatening to take or anything maybe I
should fianchetto this Bishop this might
also prepare at five at some later stage
he cannot really play d4 because of the
pressure I have only four on the other
hand this Bishop is also slightly biting
on granite it's not it's not a really
great position for the bishop okay if
you place f4 it opens up my bishop on g7
maybe he will do it anyway to have some
some kind of play in the pollution but
then it's certainly a double-edged
decision okay I'll take it so what now
what about 90 97 c 5s is probably on
going 92 g form
okay i'm not i'm not quite sure how to
how to play this it's a bit of a nothing
move admittedly yeah yeah this is not so
not so easy c6 d5 is not is not possible
they don't have a clear clear break here
anyway anywhere maybe even now the
knight on f6 maybe I should try to
reroute it attending rookie on rookie
890 87 f 5 verses are there diem
and now maybe maybe I can go see 65 now
that I'm controlling controlling an eye
five death quite a sum okay now I mean
him play this one well what c4c 65
reckon maybe this is the way to go he's
taking lots of time now but I'm not sold
on the same idea with c6
he might even just play d4 c64 and turn
not sure what what I'm doing then I
rather reroute the the Bishop to e6
controlling g6 are controlling g4 and on
e6 probably covering f7 this Bishop is
silly on b7 anyway this is curious why
is he playing that I mean Bishop c8 was
was was clear maybe I'm overlooking
something don't think he can take
anywhere here sacrifice Queenie to 22
one can play I think I can play Queen
edge for you
my idea is to take G for a night f 60-75
deserve this stuff come on I need to I
need to be a bigger guy I can go to each
form a silly setting I can yeah I hope
that I hope that isn't under there it is
sacrifice can I take it of course
hmm well it takes a but if it takes on
age 5 with the poor now I'm not sure
maybe maybe it is still on defensible I
know this this should be even good
humming okay Jack Jack Jack okay yeah
okay how is he doing this it's a [ __ ]
like Oh what why am I so slow yeah yeah
yeah what what the heck was how is he
even allowed to play in this pool with
this leg usually they have they have a
lack cap so you cannot this is amazing
I'm doing instant moves all the time and
he's spending that nothing how is this
possible yeah well forget about that um
yeah okay love from the pure chess
content I was certainly certainly losing
but this list now of course is it's over
for white you've got basically a video
look down here on top edge war and
I should really win this 15 seconds but
I'm not not quite sure how he managed to
her to do that okay well I didn't feel
like like it i was i was very slow but
probably awards i don't know yeah well I
know using and looking at this stuff
just just a piece up yeah i don't know
i'm also curious um maybe around here i
should have shouldn't have played Bishop
e7 enter to take the take the chance to
play d5 now for example but it's really
am I need to refute this opening d
fibers are probably better allowing this
oh it's not a problem but it's not like
I'm a much better which I really should
be after he's giving up this Bishop
they're not much better but I should I
should have have an edgy as black yeah
thanks for watching